I don't want to welcome to this video
playing to walk I forgotten what he
plays he plays a Carl mmhmm yeah okay I
don't have really great weapon against
the car calm I play the two nights and
he plays Bishop age 5 which is not good
but needs to be no one and I don't know
it i only know like roughly how it is
how it is played check so let's see what
we can do we will probably get some some
kind of position and but what here
Queenie two or something this is also a
move I think and he goes queen with a
flag instantly I have any way every move
doesn't matter um Queen B 6
I don't know this one not my thought my
field of expertise okay let's see if I
can get to the bishop okay so it's
basically giving up a piece here right
this is small squares f3 but it's it's a
very shaky looking position for white
cell it's very open it seems a bit weird
that it should work for black but maybe
it does it is quite quite strange
position okay he just liked on c2 it's
still something okay if I take here this
Queen takes be five so i have to take
here first check the check after all
[Music]
you
so I think I should have to take here
then it takes it at the end here
and so let's see here can I somehow
castling long looks crazy in this
position it really does maybe maybe just
this one actually threatening to take on
me five
looks a bit unnatural to put it in this
in this diagonal it okay so i take he
and what's the deal I put the bishop on
d4 yeah so yeah he wants to take you
should see five those kind of things
[Music]
can you have one King g2 that's what I'm
doing next now it should be ok
I expect rook c8 I cannot cast I am
because we give form but king of 1 G 2
looks looks ok
maybe I could have played a 3 as well
yeah I'll take with this just making
that the bishop very very protected the
honda for the thing is i have some
attacking ideas myself so it seemed
Queen a six-hour playing for one movies
ok
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so what happens here tween age 6 I just
take it see having anything there you
can check me my chikis a little bit a
little bit of pudding
yeah time morning let's play something
really safe and then take on age 6
I'm a bit cautiously because I've lost a
couple of really good positions against
this player because I just didn't pay
enough attention in the position yeah
glad yeah so you can just win the ending
now or but I want to meet and to play
from made his king is so far more open
check check threatening look at six okay
check that's also ok check
black resides okay so yeah I don't know
I really don't know the opening and then
it's some line where black is
sacrificing this piece it's always hard
to tell with this play a place every
move instantly in the opening no matter
if it's a theoretical move or whatever
he just plays it so you cannot really
say you know he's playing quickly you
must know something or whatever I just
yeah this is the computer things f1 a
little bit skeptical yeah just a depth
dry name in such a complicated position
yeah okay i need to i needed to play
something reasonably quickly and I did
yeah this is really a question now I see
he's losing a piece but you see well f6
castles wow this is what he played the
engine gives castles that's crazy so
this is the computer line and now if I
take this route cheeks oh my god okay so
this this this and ultimately I take man
that looks good for white but that's a
completely create a line well okay he
went here f3 and then took here looks
you one given by the end check put this
I don't think that this should be bad
looks fairly logical takes takes 5 22
654 rookie one yeah playing the engine
moose I was also thinking about this
immediately it it also should work with
why not the idea a three maybe but King
f1 g2 mix
since six yeah now okay the thing is
this is so these are the kind of things
check that ok I have c4 here what this
is hanging ok so if he takes I actually
do win check check check crazy a typical
computer line ok but i just went here
and avoided trickery playing for yeah
here you know here i can take on age six
but i was a little bit unsure if she
texts me here share check but i can go
here i am ok and i'm really because made
us sorry IAM maid comes first mmhmm yeah
china plate plate on the safe side check
check and here i couldn't play but
should be three immediately check check
not much that you can do anyway mmm yeah
this is all about the opening no idea
really i think there are lines where
black can give this piece and it's a
completely complete mess okay thanks for
watching
[Music]